okay we're a minute away from starting
today's uh language workout
and i look forward to interacting with
you um
wait a minute here until it's actually
10 o'clock
um
unfortunately there's some kind of a
vehicle outside
pumping or whatever they're doing
spraying and it's
giving us a little bit of noise
uh we'll wait another
30 seconds or so
uh and then we will get started
and and i'll talk a little bit at first
about my day yesterday
and i'd be interested to hear from
others uh in your uh comments about uh
how the 90 day
challenge is going and what you were
doing i wish they would leave out there
it's kind of noisy
um let's see now
um
okay it's ten o'clock
welcome to the uh
second of our language workouts
and what i'm going to do is sort of go
over my day because after all i'm on the
90-day challenge that means i'm doing
something every day as i said earlier
there's a bit of a noise outside there's
nothing i can do about it
um
talk about what i did yesterday and
today i want to focus in on you know
selecting the right content and i'm
going to show you some of the things
that i do today we're also i'm going to
reference my arabic uh friday i will be
talking about some of the same things uh
it's as far as farsi is concerned again
remember that i'm gonna spend basically
one half of the week
on arabic and one half of the week on
farsi which is not ideal
uh it's not ideal because a i have less
time to spend on the one language and b
as i'm looking for words sometimes if
i'm trying to speak arabic farsi pops
into my head so it's not ideal
it does have the advantage that it
provides me with some refreshment you
know it changes the the language that
i'm learning
anyway
so yesterday
first of all on monday on monday we had
the first uh workout
and i followed that up with a
conversation in arabic with my tutor
dalia who's an excellent tutor
and i have to admit that i really
struggled i really struggled which was a
little discouraging
i felt that i spoke worse than i had on
previous occasions
certainly worse than when i was in
morocco
and so there are a couple of reasons for
that it could be interference from farsi
uh i think it could also be
because uh i had my first workout and i
had some glitches and using the system
and i was a little bit kind of uh you
know tense i guess
and
language learning is not different from
many other activities if you are somehow
tense you're gonna do less well
and and the other thing of course i
guess two other things uh one you know
we don't improve in a straight line we
do well some days we do less well other
way other days and probably our
subjective evaluation is not really that
accurate
other people don't notice these
differences but we feel them so anyway
that happened on monday so tuesday
i spoke to dalia again
and i did much better
and dahlia sent me my my report from my
discussion as well as a recording and so
i'm able to review those and i'll get
into that
in the body of the discussion today when
i talk about you know a strategy for
content how do you choose the right
content
but the other conclusion i took from my
call it failure to do well in my
discussion on monday
is that uh maybe i've got to move away
i've spent so much time on these mini
stories 50 times for less and stuff
i'm tired of them and this is going to
happen and i've done this before i've
moved away from them when i go back to
them they're now new they're fresh and i
discover new things so you can't keep on
you know
mining the same mind you have to come
out sort of go out there and find some
new stuff so let me show you on uh
and the other thing i'm going to show
you too is uh i tried to use
uh link and i encountered some
difficulty in saving phrases and it was
because i was not using it properly
and i will show you now how you're
supposed to do that so without further
ado let's share my screen
now
hopefully everyone can now see my screen
um
you know
as i come into the link every day of
course there's all kinds of
of uh content here
attractive potentially attractive
content
that i could go for
basically it's it's either
what other people have studied
or completed or some of the
news sites that we scrape as it's called
where we bring
uh you know items in typically without
audio
however
many of these like this al jazeera i
would love to do this but i just find it
too difficult so i'm in that spot
i'm sure many of you have been there
where the easy stuff is is easy but it's
getting boring and the difficult stuff
is too difficult so so yesterday
i said okay you know i'm maybe i've the
well has run dry and so far as the many
stories in arabic are concerned i'm
going to attempt some of this difficult
stuff
and you know if you look at my uh my
lessons here
so i have you know uh i have a number of
sir francois
al jazeera i got i got difficult stuff
there that i can go after and i went
after it and it was again too difficult
i've been there before yeah i've saved a
bunch of links there but it's just and
the other thing in arabic is it's not
like i'm i'm learning polish after
russian where so many words are kind of
more or less identifiable
it's like every word is is on its own
and i can't remember them and
so i said forget it so then i remembered
that i had
just like much of this content france
van gaal
assimil i bought the assimil book
and the with the audio and i paid
someone to transcribe it and i imported
that into link i did the same for
another book called the manuel de la
model
which i also brought in so i have these
two i also have hair ups somewhere
uh but i'm not gonna go looking for it
so i have these language books that i
bought
and which i paid someone to transcribe
which i can't remember what it costs me
but
compared to
i don't know 10 lessons
in the language
um
it's cheaper and i get sort of so much
use out of it i can't share these i
contact the publisher i say can we share
these i had quite a discussion with
assimil and in the end they have not
agreed
and we want to sell their content across
our site integrated with link and they
don't agree that i don't know at any
rate we haven't been successful
but i do this for my own use so i
decided i'm going to spend more time
with these contents that i looked at
before
and so i started listening for example
to assimilate modem
and
like assimil just while making breakfast
and then cleaning up i was listening to
the the lessons at the very end of the
book and i just noticed that i was
understanding so much more than i
understood before so i think i'm going
to go in and finish assimil finish our
modem even though it's not tremendously
fascinating it's just further exposure
to the language
and um
let me just
show you
if we let's say we open us emile here
um and then i'll get back to the uh the
question of my tutors uh
so i've got all these lessons here it's
you know uh
but the one i was listening to just now
let's see
lesha okay
so we open this
and uh so this is a and we'll look at
we look at the full text so this is a
lesson that i went through a long time
ago
and then i found it too difficult and i
haven't been back since
but now i'm starting in again
so
now one of the things i wanted to show
you is that i had not understood
properly
uh
how the
headless
okay so if we say the phrase
can we
and then i move away from shall we that
will stay highlighted but the problem
occurs
when we say
one thing
now i have two phrases inside the same
phrase when that happens and i move
somewhere else the phrase is no longer
highlighted
and this was something that i didn't
realize how it worked and i said geez
it's not working the phrases aren't
highlighting because i
mostly work on my ipad where it works
slightly differently so i spoke to our
developer and he explained what you have
to do is you go into the phrase the
phrase then expands
now you'll see that as i slide in here
the box around these two phrases is
larger so then if i click in that empty
space
sorry that didn't work
aya if i click in there i will see the
two overlapping phrases
so then i can choose which of two
these two phrases i want to look at
so that's the reason why
one thing away from it is still white
when you go there you find a spot they
click on and you see the two phrases so
i
don't know if this is the best way to
deal with this
uh but that's how it works and it is
important to say phrases like i have not
gone through this i listened to it
while doing breakfast
i haven't gone through it i will go
through it and i will pick those yellow
words
yusawi
uh interesting because this came up in
my tutors report as well
uh
so come you sally have
alchemists like
what does the shirt come to
is what it says come you sell we have
alchemists
come you say we have alchemists so if i
go through this text
and then save words
and then go in and say phrases
then i've got some real good material to
work on
when i go to do my review
and i can even do things like dictation
where i'm forced to write it
now
the dilemma we have as language learners
is
whatever effort we put into intensively
trying to learn something
by doing the review by doing the
dictation
of course that's time taken away from
growing in the language by more
extensive
um reading and listening
so
you're always sort of torn between and i
talked about this before the short term
the long term
so i didn't do well in my
conversation with my tutor
obviously if i spent more time
intensively working on expressions and
phrases i will do well i will do better
in my conversation probably
but i will not be
progressing as quickly towards being
able to understand
the more difficult material you know the
uh phones find cat interview that i want
to understand
so
these are choices we choose the content
we want to listen to we choose simple
versus difficult we choose intensively
working something versus extensively
expanding
and you know that's just what you got to
do
so um
again
i'd be interested in hearing your
comments and how you deal with this
issue of of intensive versus extensive
easy content versus difficult content
really mining the content for words and
phrases versus expanding in the language
getting used to the flow of the language
come you know getting into more
interesting content
one last thing i wanted to mention here
before we and i you know i'm open to
questions uh but one other thing
that i think is very important
is
you know when i talk to my tutors at
link
i save all of the conversation reports
and now i'm making sure that they give
me a recording
of the conversation report so i collect
all my conversation reports and here you
can see that i had my and it's also a
record like i had my first conversation
in arabic
on the 8th of august
okay and so you can see all the
different people i've spoken to
uh leading up to the most recent one
with dalia
and i'm going to open up the report that
i received from dahlia
now soldier t
the uh unfortunately and this is very
important she used bullets
instead of periods and therefore the
sentence the phrases that she created
for me
don't separate so i've asked her
to do that and of course the
relationship with the tutor it's an it's
an evolving situation she at first gave
me a lot of words and then she said i
think it's better to give you complete
sentences and complete phrases i said
that's good so she did that yesterday
late last night
but because she didn't put in periods
i uh it all comes as one big text which
is okay i can still work it
but i've gone back and asked her to put
in periods so that they will be
separate sentences and if they're
separate sentences then i can even like
without separate sentences sentence view
obviously doesn't work sentence view
looks the same as
full text so it's important to put in
periods
in the tutor report
and she gave me a very vedina
so and i listened to this three or four
times this morning while making
breakfast went over the text again and
it's a great way to
relive
the conversation it's still
alive in my mind
and the great thing about conversation
reports is
you can sort of you can steer
the content so if you want to develop
vocabulary on a certain subject then you
talk about that subject and that
vocabulary is going to come up
and then of course it comes back to you
in the report both written and with the
with the audio
so it's another form of content so it
creates
so we've got the easy content that
someone else created we've got the
difficult content that might be
intrinsically more interesting
and then you have this uh content that
in effect you create with your tutor and
it stays with you and you can go back to
it whenever you want
um i think that's basically it what i
intend to do now i've been through this
if okay so what am i going to do today
i've been through this several times i'm
not going to go through it again
what i would want to do now if i were
going to sit and study right now which i
probably should since this is what i'm
supposed to be doing
uh if i i would want to go into i was
just listening to asimil i would like to
go into the
maybe i would go in like these first
ones are probably too easy
but uh
you know maybe starting around 50 and i
would go from 50 to 76 which is the last
lessons in asimil
and
really work through them saving words
and phrases
and that then prepares me
to listen to them and then i can listen
to them all
when i'm working out in the gym
and that would be my day
so
maybe i'd like to leave a little more
time now for questions
any comments or questions you have
on
how you want these
sessions to proceed questions you have
about language about language learning
please let me know
i don't know if there are any at this
point
uh
maybe not
okay
if there are none then i'm gonna start
studying here
yes
uh okay a question on learning chinese
characters
you know maybe
i should almost do a demonstration of
this
uh i can only tell you what i did when i
learned chinese characters 50 years ago
there are other
methods
available today that didn't exist 50
years ago
but 50 years ago i had a box of
cardboard characters
and very very beautifully drawn
in calligraphy
and i would take 10 to start with
and i pull up one
and i have this you know
squared paper paper with with
both vertical and horizontal lines so
it's full of squares
which means that there are columns so
then i pick up the first character and i
write the character down
the left hand column
and
you know i write it 10 15 times i found
in those days that i had first of all i
was required to write in chinese so
there was no option of not writing like
today i don't learn to write i'm not
going to write arabic by hand i don't
even write you know russian by hand i'm
learning for fun but in those days i was
paid by the canadian government to learn
chinese i had to be able to write in our
final exam we had to translate editorial
newspaper editorials from english to
chinese i had to write diplomatic notes
in chinese i had to be able to write so
there's no
question there i just had to write so i
would write one character 10 15 times
down the left-hand column and then put
the character face down and then i would
write either the the sound the
pronunciation of that character or the
meaning in english three columns over
then i would pick another character and
i would write it down 10 or 15 times and
then also put the meaning or translation
a few columns over and i would keep
doing that and by the time i picked up
the third character or the third card i
would run into the first one you know
the english or the sound of that
character
and then i would have to write it again
another five six times so it was it was
like long before
anyone
before i had heard a spaced repetition
it was my own primitive space repetition
system and i started out with 10 a day
and i got it up to 30 a day
every day just about
but the thing to remember is that 10 a
day or 30 a day you're gonna forget most
of them
so i had to constantly reshuffle ones
that presumably or ostensibly i had
learned
back into the deck because you're
constantly forgetting
and i did that for the first thousand
and thereafter
just through a lot of reading and i was
a massive reader of chinese more than
any of the other students studying with
me i had already you know figured out
that listening and reading were the keys
to learning the language and so then
when i came across new characters i
would write them out somewhere but it
wasn't a systematic sort of
this sort of
primitive space repetition system it was
just a matter of getting used to writing
them and then we had assignments where
we had to write so i was exposed to the
character through reading and writing
and
basically in the first nine ten months
uh i learned i don't know three four
thousand characters i read my first
novel in chinese after seven months lots
of characters i didn't know
but uh it worked
so that was one question okay do i find
french or german to be harder to learn
impossible for me to say because i had
french at school i lived in france for
three years as a university student did
all my you know
studying and writing essays and
everything in french so french was for
me it was just
yeah i went added very methodically
german i learned uh
you know uh
i would say german
i never struggled with grammar in french
because i had so much exposure to the
language whereas in german i had to make
the decision to not try to memorize the
declension tables i would never get
anywhere and once i took the decision
that i am going to make mistakes in
german but i want to get exposure to the
language i got a flow a rhythm of the
language my my german improved i make
more mistakes in german than in french
intrinsically which one is more
difficult i can't say if you're starting
from scratch
then a question here how do you keep up
with all the languages that you know
okay
there is no if i only if i decided to
sort of really improve in even french or
japanese or chinese or spanish which are
some of the language that i speak you
know better
i could do a really good job on them so
once you've got this many languages of
course you can't maintain them all at
the same level
however what i find is that if if i
learn the language through massive
listening and reading if my brain has
been exposed to so much of the content
so much of the language
then i am rusty when i start into it
but i very quickly get back to where i
was and then get better
so i don't worry about
keeping up with all these languages i
can't possibly
uh read in 20 languages every day or
maybe i could but i don't because i you
know there's only so much time in the
day and i'm as it is devoting my time to
two languages which is not ideal
so
i don't worry about maintaining them uh
i think that
and if i do need to brush up let's say
you know as has happened i'm invited to
come on television in vancouver and
speak in mandarin then i'll spend a
couple of hours listening to some of my
mandarin cds or reading in chinese
or
yeah and i have done the same for
italian or spanish
listening and reading again kind of
seems to refresh the neurons that you
need for that for that language
which is your favorite language is a
question here i don't have a favorite
language i am typically
obsessed with the language that i'm
trying to learn
and in this case arabic and farsi
and
i just find them fascinating for
themselves
and also for what they conjure up
uh you know arabic
i mean arabic there's there's the
pre-islam arab and
poetry and things of that nature there
you know i was in petra jordan which is
this amazing site where the community of
arabs
pre-islam who
carved
these these wonderful
uh
column sculptures architecture out of
the sand you've got the whole andalucia
on the luthia there's so much in our
culture and
that i know nothing about and similarly
in pharmacy i mean persia has been a
major force in world history so the
opportunity to get engaged with those
languages i find that totally
fascinating but i feel just as excited
when i'm doing greek or russian or so i
don't have a favorite language i just
like engaging with
languages whatever they may be
okay
uh so i'll just continue studying here
because that was the idea and if there
are questions i will answer them
so
here
oh
but notice i'm changing a hint here
but it's such a useful
phrase
that i've decided i'm going to review it
again
ahiran
foreign
now i like to listen to the text of
speech in arabic because i'm not
always so confident of my ability to
read arabic
[Music]
and i'll sometimes correct the uh
the hints if i think that's a more
appropriate
um
translation
she back
so it's a wind window
washington
how long realistically does it take to
learn your first language i've been
learning italian for stranded for that
and i'm still really struggling
okay
uh how long does it take
um
first of all
uh you know when you say struggling it
depends on what your expectations are
we struggle for a long long time
and i think it's very important to
feel a sense of achievement for what we
are able to do rather than worrying
about what we cannot do
it's it's first of all it's realistic
second of all it keeps us going i think
whenever we have a sense of achievement
we are encouraged we feel good about
ourselves we're in inclined to want to
continue
um
you know
seven months struggling okay i've been
i've been learning arabic for more than
a year off and on i have
according to my statistics 7 000
known words in arabic
and i bet you i struggle more in arabic
than you struggle
in italian this is a question from
nicholas jones
um
yeah i mean
if you knew spanish you would learn
italian more quickly because you'd have
so much of the vocabulary and the
grammar
um
i think you you know there is no
you know it depends what languages we
know it depends what our activities are
uh it depends what you mean by
struggling are you struggling to read
the newspaper are you struggling to
speak
um
at some point when we have accumulated
personally by the way i don't think 4
500 known words is a lot i think that
in my experience like even with chip
which i studied for eight months and i
already had russian
uh i struggled for quite a while in
speaking
and i think when you get to 15 000 known
words
you won't be struggling as much in other
words we need a lot of words because the
known words is not only an indication of
what you know it's also an indication of
how much of the language you have
exposed yourself to
and so it's kind of a milestone
um
and then at some point and i mean you
can start at the typically to me 5 000
words is a good place at which to start
speaking
uh
but when you get to 10 to 15 000 words
you now have enough that you can
understand what people are saying a lot
of it and then you have to start
speaking a lot because eventually to
speak well you have to speak a lot but
seven months 4 500 known words
struggling to me that's absolutely
normal and and i wouldn't get down on on
myself nicholas here's another question
from tom
uh in your session they do you focus on
modern standard arabic or do you discuss
dialects
so of course the problem in arabic is
that there are no native speakers of
modern standard arabic so
if your tutor is from like my tutor is
of uh sort of i think jordanian or
palestinian background
i've had tutors of egyptian background
uh i presume their
version of modern standard arabic is
influenced by their local dialect the
local language actually
but we only talk in modern standard
arabic
and i have made that decision based on
the fact that i don't know if i'm going
to be interacting with people from
jordan lebanon iraq
you know saudi arabia
egypt
so if i learn the modern standard arabic
i can access whatever's on the internet
i can access
you know podcasts
newspaper articles
books
and at some point if i know that i'm
going to be needing a particular form of
arabic then i will have a good base from
which to learn that form of arabic it
may be that i decide to go for egyptian
arabic simply because there are so many
movies available in egyptian arabic but
it depends what my motivation is going
to be
so
that's that we're now kind of at the end
i'm going to go back to studying my
assimil text here
if there are no further questions then i
and i appreciate any comments you have
on how we can make these sessions more
interactive would be appreciated i hope
you find them useful
and so now i'm going to shut it down